[Musique]
Je crois que chaque vie a une valeur et que
chaque vie a une dignité
c'est
[Musique]
une conviction
qu'il a fait de moi la personne que je suis
et mes autres garçons les personnes qu'ils
sont
donc sa vie a une valeur inestimable
[Musique] les
gens  besoin de pouvoir prendre des décisions
sur ce qui se passe dans leur corps
est-
ce que c'était particulièrement dévastateur parce que
j'ai découvert que le lendemain j'avais moi-même
eu un
avis d'avortement inutile et médicalement nécessaire
[Applaudissements]
Républicain
électoral les
questions de protections que
nous avons ensemble  réseau de personnes qui
participent activement à aider les mères
lorsqu'elles choisissent de donner naissance à leurs
bébés et
euh pendant des années après aussi dondus
j'avais l'habitude de voter pour un démocrate
euh qui était mon représentant au
congrès et il était un démocrate pro-vie
et  vous ne pouvez plus être pro-vie dans la plupart des endroits
et être un politicien démocrate
Je crains vraiment que mes filles n'aient pas
les mêmes privilèges en grandissant que
j'avais il y a à peine un an Carol Kane
i  t a enhardi des
gens qui
ne seraient peut-être pas motivés à voter
parce qu'avoir un droit que les femmes
avaient depuis près de 50 ans leur a été enlevé du
jour au lendemain même si vous n'étiez pas d'accord avec
le concept de vraiment bouleverser beaucoup de
gens, tout ce domaine était rempli
avec les gens, la
même procédure est appliquée s'ils le choisissent ainsi
les partis politiques nous forcent
à un extrême ou à l'autre c'est que nous ne
nous rencontrons pas au milieu nous ne
savons pas trouver un terrain d'entente
Dieu je ne fais plus confiance à ce pays
je  Je suis vraiment dévasté par le nombre de
personnes dans ce pays, je suis devenu
si extrême
, nous devons donc revoir ceci est
mon message aux électeurs, c'est que vous
devez soutenir les candidats qui soutiennent les
droits humains fondamentaux et pour l'instant
cela semble  soyez les démocrates, cette
élection est très importante et les gens
doivent sortir et voter pour
avoir accès aux soins de santé, il saute, il
adore ça, je serais plus en
faveur de la polarisation pro-vie,
je remplis ce truc comme
e  Chaque jour,
je crois que vous savez que chaque vie
compte, mais je crois aussi que vous
savez qu'il y a certaines
circonstances différentes où je pense que l'avortement
devrait être autorisé
Je pense que les républicains font mieux que
si nous avions parlé il y a un mois Je pense que les
républicains le feront  s'en sortir mieux ici dans le
Michigan et aussi à Washington à cause
de l'économie
Angeles
j'encourage tous ceux qui ont une femme dans
leur vie à sortir et à voter et à voter en
pensant à ces femmes dans votre vie
Lisa
réconciliation cela ouvrirait enfin la porte à la
discussion au problème  résoudre pour
dire d'accord
comment pouvons-nous soutenir les gens
[Musique]
est